one two three okay let's go
[Music]
let's roll the cameras
we're 16 32.
black against
canvas too from Turkey okay
and we have ourselves a Sicilian
and are we finally going to get an open
Sicilian for the first time in the
speedrun
no still no open Sicilian but the next
best thing we get our rosalimo and if
you're a self-respecting accelerated
Dragon player worth your salt
you definitely need to know how to face
the rosalima we have faced it once when
we were about 1300 1320 and those of you
who watch the Speed Run assiduously
might remember that we actually faced a
very very reasonable opponent who
demonstrated pretty good knowledge of
White's main rostolimo ideas and at one
point I was even worse
to quickly summarize what is available
to Black in this position there are
maybe four or five reputable moves but
the two main ones are G6 and E6 and
which move you should decide to play
primarily depends on what you play
against the open Sicilian the Same by
the way goes for choosing a line against
uh two knights C3 if you are a uh time
on off player or a pal or a con player
then you normally gravitate toward E6
just because you get the similar type of
structure when you play E6 here if you
are an accelerated player then to me it
makes the most sense to play the most
popular move in the position which is G6
our opponent castles
and white has sort of one major fork in
the road there are variations where
white takes the Knight on C6 this is the
sort of traditional main line but more
recently a lot of top GMS have been
playing kind of a cross between a
rosalimo and an elephant and playing the
move C3 either in this position or after
canceling so let's see if our opponent
does indeed choose the fashionable C3
variation which I play myself
well we don't have much of a choice we
feed and keto our Bishop
and in this position okay rookie one so
rookie one is to my knowledge not uh a
super popular move but it's obviously
not I mean a move like rookie one can't
be bad white keeps maximum flexibility
white white keeps the option open of
taking the Knight on C6 I'm already out
of theory we're basically on our own
here how should we develop if you're
looking at this for the first time then
you're probably leaning toward just
moving the night out to F6
but if you watched uh sort of the
previous rosalimo game then you might be
a little bit better acquainted with some
of Black's typical setups here and there
is a move that I would imagine nobody
would ever want to play unless you're
specifically familiar with uh the setup
that this move is a part of
and uh this this move is actually E5 E7
E5 and it's a hard move to explain on
the basis of general principles alone
because if you look at this move what
might jump out at you is that it blocks
in the bishop that's a negative it
creates major holes in the center that
seems to be another negative
and there don't seem to be any obvious
positives of pushing the pawn out to E5
and yet that's exactly what we're going
to do so I'm going to zero in on the
reasons for which we play it after the
game because I could potentially take 10
minutes uh to explain why E5 is an
effective move in the rosalima for black
it's not an easy thing to explain even
if I have access to the board but I
definitely need access to variations uh
to help you understand the rationale
behind E5 so for now I'm going to play
it and hopefully the course of the game
also teaches you a little bit about why
E5 is an effective move Knight to C3 our
opponent is developing normally now the
first good thing about playing E5 is
that the Knight gets an additional
development square and as you know when
there's a bishop on B5 and it's making
contact with the Knight on C6 it's
generally a good idea for the knights to
link up right when the knights link up
that just is a compact nice way of
developing and by playing E5 we are
opening up for ourselves a square on E7
for the night where we're gonna put it
Knight sheet E7
and we're gonna follow up of course by
playing Pawn to D6 another positive of
the pawns on E5 and C5 much like in the
marozzi bind which white can play
against the accelerated
these pawns are combining to seriously
clamp down on the D4 Square in fact that
square is protected one two three four
times by our pieces and pawns making it
virtually impossible that white is ever
going to play D4 and our opponent plays
D3 which is not such a big deal but
White's a little bit more cramped In the
Sicilian when they don't play D2 D4 okay
so here we can obviously Castle kingside
but I would prefer for us to start by
playing the move D6 I don't like the
fact that the bishop is closed off by
the pawns and holding off on castling
can actually bear fruit so for instance
if white plays Bishop to G5 we can
conceivably play H6 and then G5 and if
we're not castled yet we can actually
keep our King in the center or even
Castle it to the queen side and then
we'll have carte blanche on the king
side just to attack with our pawns whoa
Jabo hookies are the 5000 bits holy
smokes let's go D6
and not castling castling a little bit
later than you normally would is a very
Advanced technique that needs to be done
with tremendous amount of caution
because if you could leave your king in
the center too long that comes with a
lot of risks but here we benefit
directly from the way we've positioned
our pawns right white is never going to
be able to open up the center D4 is
never a possibility and so keeping the
king in the center is a totally sensible
course of action there we go there's
Bishop G5 there's Bishop G5
so
We have basically two ways in which we
can set our King side Pawns in motion
and this is going to be some very very
Advanced positional chess
we can play the move H6 but what is my
worry
uh in regards to the move H6 My worry is
not that white is going to drop back to
H4 that runs right into our scheme we're
gonna play G5 and then we can play H5
later that looks great
my slight worry is that after age six
yeah exactly white takes on E7 we can't
take back with the Knight we have to
take back with the queen and then white
plops the Knight on D5 with tempo
forcing Our Queen back and then white
pushes the C Pawn out and potentially
prepares D4
so black is fine there we would Castle
King site and the game would continue I
think you added him for the 10 Subs oh
my gosh but I think there's another way
in which we can achieve our main plan of
essentially attacking on the king side
without allowing white to take this
Knight on E7 and establish control of
the important D5 square and this is a
move that obviously your brain
automatically cancels out because of its
reputation but I don't think there's
anything inherently wrong with it in
this position anytime the center is
completely closed you can often play
moves that with an open Center would be
totally Unthinkable because of how
weakening they are but I like the move
F6 here
Bishop comes back to E3 maybe our
opponent would have done that anyway
against H6 okay so since the bishop
comes back to E3
I think we need to change our plans
slightly against Bishop H4 we would have
played G5 now we could still play G5 and
then H5 and that's a viable scheme but
because the move G5 no longer comes with
Tempo I think we should instead make the
emphasis on completing our development
and especially anytime you play F6 you
have to be very careful about the A2 G8
diagonal which you weaken and that's why
F6 is often accompanied by the bishop
development to E6 we're just covering
the diagonal that we just weakened our
opponent continues to play instantly
so we've completed our development of
everything except our King
we could consider castling Queen side
here but I would be very worried about
white blasting open the queen side with
like A3 and B4
so let's play things in a slightly more
uh tame Manor and I think we should just
Castle kingside I think the time has
come for us to Castle kingside our
opponent might be preparing Bishop H6
but our Bishop is not really the pride
of our position uh I totally don't mind
giving it away uh or trading it off and
I actually think we have a very nice
position and what really hurts white is
his inability to push D4 white really
doesn't have anything sexy going on any
side of the board while we have Superior
control of the center visually our
pieces might look more passive and our
Pawn structure might look
sketchy but it's not sketchy at all we
don't have a single weakness in our
position we have managed to defend the
square on D5 with two of our minor
pieces making Knight T5 impossible okay
now we need to transition from sort of
the developmental phase to the phase
where we actually transform
our development our nice development
into something concrete and the position
is closed which means we need to be very
patient and we need to put the emphasis
on
kind of gradually improving our position
nothing happens too fast in positions
like these okay so let's think about
what's available to us
hmm I'm going to take a moment to think
here
I have a pretty cool idea
and again we are violating rules left
and right like this is another move that
violates a positional Rule and not only
that but it it contradicts what I just
said
right well we have put two of our minor
pieces such that the D5 score is
protected and the A2 G8 diagonal is
guarded by the bishop but
since we have Castle kingside a
potential White Bishop check on C4 is
not dangerous at all our King just moves
over to h8 so the weakness of that
diagonal is no longer essential
and I think our Knight on E7 is
perfectly perfectly capable of guarding
the D5 Square on its own right notice
that if white puts a knight on D5 let's
say our Bishop isn't there and we take
back white has to take back with a pawn
and you know that weak squares are best
occupied with a piece if they're
occupied with a pawn
that's not dangerous for us at all in
fact it gets rid of our weakness for us
nimsovich was the first to sort of
formulate that idea so what idea am I
really getting at here well there's a
weird move that may seem to fall prey to
one moveitis but it's actually a threat
which is quite hard to Parry and I'm
talking as some of you are indicating
about the move Bishop to G4 now what do
we even want well obviously we want to
take the Knight and completely ruin
White's kingside Pawn structure they
might say well didn't have a nice set
previously that you shouldn't make moves
that only intend to ruin Pawn structure
so again
it's it's not the pawn structure that's
important it's the fact that White's
King is on the king side so if we're
able to take on F3 we will plop our own
Knight on the equivalent weak Square on
D4 and we'll already be threatening a
fork
and our Queen has very easy access to
that H3 Square so we're actually trying
to deliver Checkmate that's the point of
Bishop G4
and that Knight on F3 this is the sort
of motivation behind this move doesn't
have all that many retreating squares in
fact it only has one and that's super
ugly Square on H4 okay obviously we take
back
now if white can't move the Knight then
white has to defend it but there's also
not that many ways to defend and the
bishop can't jump over the pawn
if white goes Queen to E3 and this is
really what I had to see it or Rook to
E3 we have a very nice follow-up and we
start taking control of the initiative
the rook and the Knight are in forkable
squares you have to notice that
so if a pawn appears on D4 that's a fork
so the move stems very naturally from
that observation
yeah F5 is a great move here I think F5
is actually a viable alternative
in fact it might even be better than
what I was planning to do let me think
about this again for another second the
move that I was thinking about of course
is Knight C6 to D4
but after Knight T4 white has this very
weird defensive move the Knight actually
now has the E1 Square as a retreating
Square
so F5 is a phenomenal alternative we are
trying to drive that pawn down to F4
Kick The Rook out of the way and then
take the Knight on F3 I really like both
of those moves
so 94 91 I'm just trying to find a
follow-up in that position if we find a
good follow-up we'll go Knight T4
I mean we could play F5 in that position
absolutely
or we could play F5 in this position
it's one of those things both of these
options look so good
but what I like about the move F5
is that it also threatens to win
material like if white moves the Knight
then we play F4
and we potentially trap The Rook
Hmm this is actually a very hard choice
and I'm not pretending to be thinking
I'm actually
trying to assess both of these options
okay let's go for our initial intention
and play Knight T4
I think this move is going to be very
hard for white to to face practically
speaking
I vote Knight D4 and I'm the dictator
here so sorry
okay well the move worked like a charm
okay now I think I know what our
opponent has missed I think our opponent
wants to go Rook to G3 in a in a way I
wish we would have played F5 because
that would have been a little bit more
meat on the bone what our opponent
forgot about is that when we take the
Knight we're simultaneously attacking
the queen right that is something I
didn't point out and now our opponent
starts thinking
now we faced a couple of players now
who've just like played the opening in
early middle game phase instantly and
then only start thinking when they
blunder something
now the game is far from over we've got
a extra piece for a pawn but it's it's
not you know our we still have a little
bit of work to do okay well I guess not
we would have dropped our Bishop back to
E6
and then deployed Our Queen over to B6
and then brought our Rook to C8 I mean
all the pieces really come in
but that was a pretty anti-climactic
ending unfortunately
okay let's have a look
let's have a look
so we Face the rosalimo
and then we play the move G6
and
when we face this for the first time I
gave you sort of a general rundown of
the possibilities that both sides have
so I would sort of redirect you to that
video I won't just repeat myself in that
game we did face Bishop takes C6 and
then we took back with the d-pawn in
order to open up the bishop and we
actually played something very similar
uh to what we did in this game
I think white played D3 and let me see
if I can find that game
was it this guy no this is the guy who
played a pretty darn good game this
might have been in the previous speed
run
just trying to find this guy this guy
yeah this might have been in a previous
speeder so I won't look too hard for it
no it wasn't this game either
anyways
I think what we faced was Bishop C6 DC
D3 the point I'm trying to make is that
in this position I think we played
Bishop to G4 we we traded the bishop for
the night
and then we play the move E5 like we or
no no we didn't we didn't play Bishop Q4
we just played E5 straight away
so it's the same general type of Pawn
structure which is aimed at preventing
D4 and establishing kind of a very
watertight clamp in the center and
there's a lot of theory in this position
so I'll redirect you to that other game
here we faced a fundamentally different
setup where white does not take the
Knight on C6 and as I said the move C3
here has gotten exceedingly popular it's
actually the recommendation of Wesley in
his E4 course I have played it with
white and here the main line goes much
like in the elephant by the way Knight
F6 now the old move which I've played a
lot is to play this literally like an
elephant E5 Knight T5 D4 but black
equalizes here pretty easily after cdcd
uh black
castles Knight C3 and to my knowledge
the best move here is to drop the Knight
back to C7 and quickly try to smash
through the center with D6
um there are some crazy lines here where
white plays Bishop G5 I had a blitz I
had a couple Blitz games like this
takes takes a six
and here white has this move Knight to
D6
using the pin against the e-pawn things
get wild here there's a line where black
plays H6 white drops Back in Black plays
G5 and it looks like black is one a
piece
uh because if the bishop moves then you
take the Knight if the Knight moves you
take the bishop but white has the
sacrifice on G5
and after HG white sacrifice is another
piece and here there is a move which
almost nobody knows if you don't find
this move you lose the game so almost
everybody who I've had this position
against in Blitz they take the Knight
and stumble into Queen H5
and the point is okay black can give up
the queen but that's basically losing
but the move Rook E8 may seem like it
yields a draw because white as two
pieces down so it it may appear that you
have to repeat moves but you don't white
is completely winning after Queen G6
threatening mate and now the very Zen
move F4 is just crushing because white
threatens F5 F6 and these pieces are
totally unassailable like there's just
nothing black and do black is not
developed so for instance after Knight
D4 he just rushed the pawn down F5 this
is a cool line
a def six and it's just made
and the just the the power of you know a
couple well-placed attacking pieces
rookie six okay rookie six where F4
rookie six is the top engine move but
now you go here
here or sorry you go Queen H7 check
you you force the king onto the f file
so that there's an x-ray and now you
play F5 beautiful stuff Queen G5 Effie
is a check that's why we gave that check
on H7
and here there's some beautiful lines
you give another check with a rook
and you can take the bishop on G7 but
even better is to set up a discovered
mate against the king with Queen G8 and
look at this mate 97 Rook F6 double
check and mate
just amazing mating position both pieces
I love it when both pieces when it's a
double mate and both pieces are hanging
just the power of the double check is on
display here
yeah no it's these are really cool lines
so that's why I like this so much for
white
but there's a party pooper and by the
way F5 Rook H6 traps the queen
and here there is a show stopper for
white I'll let you guys try to find
White's move this is like the and I know
we're not flipping the board because I
don't want to flip the board too many
times we're ultimately looking at this
from black side so
um you'll have to burrow that white to
plan win
beautiful move
you're gonna be down three pieces at
some point
not Queen G6 because if you play Queen
G6 it's just one check and then I'll
move my king to G8 you run out of gas
Knight to E6 is correct so the right
idea to open up the f file but you do it
by sacrificing the least amount of
material
so if black moves the king then the
queen is free to free to go
takes takes check white is down three
pieces
and that's it King has to move and the
queen meanders past the bishop and
delivers mate
no technically the best move is Rook F6
but now you actually play Rook takes F6
with the idea Bishop F6 Queen F7 mate
so
yeah so this is very enjoyable stuff and
all of this is Uncorked once you play
out for you have to know this move F4
so I can show you more lines but you
kind of get the get the gist of it
so the problem is that there's a party
pooper in this position the party pooper
is this move F7 F6 I mean very hard move
to to play but the move should make
sense the piece that you really need to
eliminate is this Knight on G5 that's
the bane of Black's existence
and the position is very unclear white
plays e takes F6 now again if you play
EF which people have done against me
suddenly the queen moves to the other
side of the board Queen B3 check
and obviously there's a fork
right as I said anytime you push the F
Pawn you have to keep tabs on the a2ga
diagonal and vice versa obviously if
White Checks here black has E6 so after
EF black has to play Rook F6 and I think
according to Modern entrance black is
slightly better here if the game goes on
it's just a super complicated position
black has a piece but white has two
pawns and white is this monster Knight
and you can analyze this on your own I
haven't plugged this into stockfish 15
so I don't know what the the current
assessment of this line is now long
story short this is not forced so black
can also for example if he wants to
avoid this take on C3 and play the line
which a lot of people play against me
and Blitz which is takes in D6 but I was
always under the opinion that in a
position like this white is a little bit
better
um but perhaps Bishop B6 kind of
clamping down on the light squares is
the equalizing line
so anyways
the thing is recently almost everybody
is playing the move Rook to E1 and this
is what Wesley recommends so the point
is to avoid playing E5 and to play D4 in
one Fell Swoop and here
you get a position where widest control
of the center but black counter strikes
with D5
and this is a very theoretical position
karawana Carlson you can find tons of
super games in this position
it appears that white might be slightly
better but the jury is still out so this
position is super topical
um there's Knight C3 there's Bishop to
E3 I mean there's there's a ton of
different types of moves here I think
Wesley recommends this and then
like Knight bd2 so
yeah white is a little bit better here I
think in any case
um
in any case I hopefully we'll get
another roast limo and I'll delve a
little bit more extensively into the
theory from Lex perspective
our opponent went rookie one
and we immediately play this movie five
so hopefully I did a halfway decent job
of already explaining what the rationale
is behind this move
and um it's one of those things that
visually looks extremely unappealing but
the more you look at it the more you
understand that the purported defects of
this move aren't all that bad
so let's go one by one
first of all it blocks in the bishop
well as I've said before when you have a
construction with a bishop and a pawn I
like to think of this as one unit the
pawn is like an extension of the bishop
right yes the bishop controls less
squares but if you think about it the
bishop and the pawn are both controlling
the D4 Square they're like
part of the same machine and if you
think of it that way then the bishop
stops looking that bad
um
okay next point is that it weakens the
D5 Square yeah but as you saw we're able
to put a knight on E7 and potentially a
bishop on E6 and it's actually very hard
for white to occupy the D5 Square
as for the D6 Square we're going to put
a pawn there so that's that week this is
going to be eradicated and the plus of
this move is just that it controls the
center in such a robust way
okay
so if I place Knight C3
we get our night out to E7 D3 D6
Bishop G5 and here I actually really
really like the move F6 another move
which looks very unappealing
H6 was possible but again
I did not want to allow white to
accomplish the task of getting the
Knight to D5 but really this is not bad
for black either
I really don't think that black is any
worse in this position
and if you play the sevashnikov Sicilian
you will know that these types of
positions are not that bad for black
because black has the very typical plan
of going F7 F5
and essentially getting stuff going
on the king side good pieces don't win
games the Knight on D5 is annoying but
black and black can live with it black
can go around it and white does not have
a clear plan in this position because
okay white can try to go D4 but that
ain't gonna cut it I mean white just
loses the pawn
so white is plagued by the fact that he
can't open the center
black is no other weaknesses so so white
is sort of at a dead end here the engine
move is A4 and that's a sign that
there's just nothing really sexy that
black can do here I would move the king
away to h8 so that there's no
shenanigans on this diagonal when we
play F5
okay Bishop C4 and already black and
seriously contemplate playing F5 yeah
the engine basically says that white
should
okay white EF is the engine move that's
not a very human move to give black you
know these pawns this has actually
happened
G3 I see a game in the database wow
this is interesting I wonder who was
playing Bishop t7 Knight H4 Bishop E8
F4
Queen D7 in complicated position
so anyways
we were spoiled for choice
in this position where we we could have
played H6 but I wanted to prevent white
from achieving his aim in playing F6
Bishop B3 Bishop B6 and again here
our plan would change based on where
white put their Bishop so in the event
of Bishop H4 I was seriously
contemplating G5
Bishop G3 and H5 and just look at this
bishop and how it's biting on granite
this bishop is terrible we're
threatening to win the bishop
and if white plays H3 we just go bang
and then bang and this is why we keep
the king in the center not just because
the king would be less safe on the Kings
but also because we actually want the
Rook to be on h8 to support to support
the move H3
this idea also occurs very frequently in
the Italian very frequently in the
Italian where you can keep your king in
the center and this Furious lightning
Pawn storm on the king side can often
result in checkmate
especially if white puts a Pawn on H3
prematurely because that pawn can be
used as a hook this move G4 is a lot
more dangerous when there is a Pawn on
H3 because white is essentially forced
to take and now there's nothing I can do
about this pin moving the queen results
in disaster because it allows Bishop
takes F3
and I had a game uh in the Italian where
I I think I demonstrated
these types of ideas
in a completely different opening let me
see if I can dig it up really quickly
this was actually one of my nicer games
on the black side of an Italian
it was a pro chessily game
where I just decided to go all out and
and it worked Justin 10 is a is now a GM
from Australia he was an IM we play this
game
here we go so let's flip the board
because we're looking from black side so
this was an Italian
and
okay so while we play the normal Italian
moves and then he plays H3
and I'm like okay the guy plays H3
before I castled so the normal move for
black is just to cut but I just decided
I'm gonna use that part as a hook and
here's what I do H6
freaking G5
and G4 I don't give a damn I'm just
taking on the bishop we got a very
similar situation
he takes it whatever Knight H5 Queen F6
Knight F4 I mean all the pieces are
coming in he's doing nothing in the
center my Center is perfectly well
defended Rook G8
right and this is why it's so good my
king in the center is perfectly safe
he's not doing anything to it bring the
other Rook into the game bring the
Knight into the game
and ultimately he started taking my
pawns but
I I won his Bishop
and then I brought my Bishop back and
sacked The Rook on G3 this is a really
nice game he can't take it
because then I take it and mate him on
H3
and I just destroyed him I just took all
his freaking pieces all of them
mate
it's funny that his King ends the game
on C1 it runs all the way to the queen
side only to get mated there
but I could show you a million games
like that this H6 G5 G4 attack
is very dangerous and it's very
dangerous when the center is closed and
when your king is relatively safe in the
center so
hopefully this this made some sense and
gives you
A New Perspective on these attacking
ideas
so that's why we would go G5 but after
Bishop E3
black could still go G5 actually but I
don't love this move when it doesn't
come with a gain of tempo
uh because it's it's harder and it takes
longer to get stuff going on the king
side but we still could have considered
instead we decided to play this more
conventionally with Bishop E6
and here I think white white starts
stumbling Queen D2 is a bit of an
aimless move and this plan that white
carried out of trading dark squared
Bishops is is a total waste of time just
a complete waste of time in fact it also
deprives the night of this Square how
would I play here with white well what I
would do is go by the logic of
exchanging Black's most important piece
the bishop on E6 is an important piece
because it controls the light squares in
the center I would play this move Bishop
to C4
now definitely black does not want to
take that opens up the D file and allows
white to attack D6 we would probably go
Queen D7
and now I would move the Knight away on
from D2 and try to quickly push F4
basically beat Black to the punch
although according to the engine black
is better after F5 so White's King
starts feeling pretty uncomfortable with
things opening up
so I don't know I think black's position
is just very very comfortable here top
engine move is like again A4 engine
doesn't really know what to do and then
black alrighty will play off five as as
we as we were planning but still I think
perhaps trading and then playing F3
gives white a very solid position
double edged
so I think Bishop C4 was the best bet
for our opponent but as you can see just
playing this with white and not opting
for one of the two main plans either
taking early or going c3d4 is just very
difficult white is really stifled here
Bishop to G4 which I think was a really
good move after rookie 3 Knight D4 is
really the beginning of the end for
white now he tooken lost the game
immediately the only move here would
have been to drop the Knight back to E1
and here we were planning to play F5 and
what I needed to see
is that after age three what should
black do who can tell me the key idea
for black this is what I spent a little
bit of time trying to calculate
yeah it's F4
so you you ask what happens if I do it
anyway and The Rook is trapped I mean
white takes it you take it that's not
the end of the story black has some work
to do but after an ip5 Knight B5 lpdo
the night is undefended the pawn is
undefended bang that's a fork A4 A6 get
Chase the night away take the pawn and
now you're a full exchange up and you're
completely winning and all this time the
Knight on E7 is playing a purely
defensive role but a very important role
it's guarding the T5 Square it's okay
for a piece to play a purely defensive
role thank you Mr loopy
so anyways
the situation after F5 is already very
dire it's like -2 white has to somehow
stumble and Bumble his way around just
to save The Rook but
after F3 we still play F4 doesn't change
anything
so the situation is terrible for white
obviously this this loses the game on
the spot and that's unfortunate but
after Knight T4 I think we're already
close to winning now at the end we would
have played Bishop back to E6 and then
maybe D5 Rook say the conversion process
here is very very straightforward also
The Rook is terrible it's just doing
absolutely nothing it's out of the game
that makes things even worse for white
that was a bit of an anti-climactic game
only 16 moves but still a lot of
positional Concepts at play there bye
[Music]